hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and ah
[Music]
checking in on you
just checking in to see how your day's
going you know what I'm going to be
honest with you man I was having
I was having the greatest [__] day
I was having the greatest day sitting
here my leather chair
um
and then I sat down to do the podcast
and I I just don't I don't know what the
[__]
it's like I I just I'm
I'm gonna sit down I'm gonna sit right
down and write myself a letter I'm going
to go on YouTube I'm going to find
whatever version of GarageBand I have
and I'm going to try and figure out why
these simplest [__] things like for
some reason I have a robot voice how do
I get rid of the robot oh I know I'll
click on voice
and there's no just [__] thing that
you clicked you got to do this and then
go into the [__] settings and this
remind reminds me of my [__] wife's
car
money she's got a smart cards the
[__] thing just thinks too much
like I have to go into settings to fix
that [__] thing
like when you approach the car the
driver's side door automatically opens
up so it's like you're walking by you're
bringing the trash barrels in if you
have the [__] key in your pocket the
[__] door opens it's like a goddamn
dog that wants to go outside
it's like nobody I'm just going up to
get a drink we're not we're not going
out and I don't want to say o u t or
you're going to start doing [__]
somersaults this is what this is what a
car is doing
I there's got to be a way in the
settings because that's what I've
learned
when I talk to people that understand
computers they always say okay go into
your settings the first thing they say
is what version of this [__]
nightmare do you have
and I'm like I
and they're like all right go into
General
click you see at the top
what does it say all right okay okay
good now go into settings
now scroll down
can you click on do you see anywhere
where it says this is easy
do you see where it says this is easy
click on that yeah that isn't on my
phone it isn't
there's nothing there that says this is
easy no nothing
hmm
well that's interesting and then there
goes the next [__] hour of your life
and you have this version of it yes and
you go into settings and it doesn't say
blah blah blah no it doesn't
can you look again hey lady I can look
all [__] day
I'm stuck in the mud here I'm on the
side of the [__] road
um
that's how that works that's how today's
[__] works
and I'm actually acting like you
actually can get a person on the phone
like you know what's hilarious like if
you actually called if you went to the
the uh
Garage Band store where there is no
[__] store
there's no person to call there's no
[__] number there's no person there's
just nothing it's like here it is you
figure it out send us an email
we'll put it in in the go [__] yourself
mailbag and maybe
like winning the lottery we'll pull
yours out and we'll have a [__] robot
give you a generic [__] answer and
that's considered customer service
as opposed
to uh I just randomly called Dean Del
Rey the other day
and I said hey man what are you doing
you know I only got a couple days left
oh I know what I said hey MotoGP
starting he's opening for me when I'm in
College Station we're going to the the
to the Moto GP race first race is today
you want to come over and watch it he
goes yeah I go where you at he goes I'm
at this service station
and I said oh cool that you know
a little out of the way I'll go you know
I swung by to go get him
and he introduces me to this mechanic
and I'm looking and the guy's got all of
these old cars he's working on
and Dean goes yeah this guy's [__]
amazing I said hey I gotta I gotta
an old F-100 that's leaking oil
you know around the transmission I I
need uh
I think I need a gasket the gasket
replaced I was told on one side of the
other but everybody I approached the
second they find out it shifts on the
column they don't want anything to do
with it and he goes bring it by bring it
by my friend
I said when he goes bring it by on
Friday I say cool I bring the [__]
thing by Friday
all right he calls me that afternoon he
said okay listen this says a little more
than blah blah than I thought it was
going to be and I said listen I don't
care what it is whatever you find it
just fix it send me the bill we're good
all right I just need this fixed I can't
this thing's been leaking in my garage
for the last 10 years he goes okay so I
get a call last night I missed it
the guy brought it in Friday yesterday
was was uh Tuesday recording here on
Wednesday
I missed the guy
because it was the end of the day I
called him this morning I go what's up
but I'm waiting for him to be like ah
the [__] aspirator too with the
[__] uh you know metaphysical uh
carburetor intake with the [__] uh
uh bungee cord I'm waiting for all of
this technical talk I said what's up he
goes it's done I go it's done he goes
yeah come down and pick it up
the guy pulled the transmission figured
out what the problem was replace the
gaskets on both sides
on both sides and what was done by
Tuesday
I I I went down to the garage I was like
floating
I was like I don't give a [__] if you
charge me [__] 90 grand I mean I
can't believe oh I give a [__] about
that but you know I can't this is
amazing
and that my friends
is has gone away with this whole new
thing and uh
of like yeah there is no customer
service there is no one to talk to there
is no phone number
it's like we got your money
we don't want to deal with you
we know that what we sold you sucks
all right slash your old and computer
illiterate and you're not going to be
able to figure it out so now you know
it's like go on YouTube and hope
somebody had the same problem and tried
to figure it out so God bless that guy
and um
I don't know about this other stuff um
you know look
let's be honest here all right most of
this is me being a [__] baby and
having add and just really not paying
attention as computers started to take
over because they never interest me
I just I don't find them interesting
I don't get excited
by new technology
in that field I find it boring as hell
I don't give a [__]
about any of it
um
I don't think my life is better now that
my entire record collection is in my
pocket
uh I think people are blowing out their
[__] ears nobody's talking to anybody
I kind of realized the other night you
know like I just turn off the um
when I hang out with my kids now
I just turned the TV off
and I tell them you know the iPad I just
tell them shut all that [__] off and
they literally complained for anywhere
from 30 seconds to about three minutes
and then after that they're running
around playing with each other
and they're playing with their toys and
I'll tell you they make a [__] mess
but I don't give a [__] because they're
not staring at those goddamn screens and
I'm just going to start doing that
more
um as opposed to uh
you know I'll do a little bit you know
they can't grow up like those kids do
you ever see that that documentary where
those [__] kids were like
sitting in that New York apartment they
were in New York City with all of these
people all of these different
races culture all his food and all this
[__] and they just stayed in there and
what was amazing though was their
imagination and they would watch movies
and then they would react they would
make all the costumes out of like cereal
boxes and [__] but like
they were sort of uh they had an
Arrested Development socially obviously
because they weren't interacting with
kids their age but um
let's take it to an extreme
[Laughter]
you know what's amazing about their dad
their dad was basically had the same
characteristics usually that type of
Personality wants to live in the middle
of nowhere
um
which we all live in the middle of
nowhere when you really
come down to it you know what I mean but
like City people's idea the middle of
nowhere which country people look at is
Paradise
um
which by the way not to bring up a
really bad subject here's a question I
have for gun owners out there
um
because now you know Liberals are
flipping out as they always do whenever
there's a school shooting
um
liberals want to take the guns away
people on the right say that's you guys
are [__] idiots that's not the
problem
all right and meanwhile not enough
people are saying is there a reason
that CNN and Fox News other than their
own diabolical going after every [__]
nickel they can
sensationalize
these things because they're not
reporting on it they're not doing
anything about it
it's like maybe if you stopped
I mean this [__] wacko chick is I
mean
I went to a diner today oh you know I
buy like a New York Post I'm old I read
the paper right and this [__] lunatic
is on the front [__] page and you
have to understand that when you do [__]
like that the same way some kid that
plays a little bit of hoop watches the
NBA he wants to get in the NBA like
shooting up a school is the NBA for
[__] psychos
so stop showing them that they're gonna
get all of this [__] attention
there's got to be something to that
because my whole life they've had these
[__] weapons
and somewhere along the line that
Columbine thing happened and ever since
then people just [__] do this [__]
but here's my question whenever they say
hey
let's take away these assault rifles you
can still have your guns just take away
the assault rifles but blah blah blah
um and that's not what they do what they
do is they they talk about gun owners
like they're [__] morons you know
classic you know what both sides do
they start
their argument off by insulting the
other people which makes the other
people completely closed off to the
argument so here's the question that I
have
as someone who doesn't own a gun but
actually likes guns
that's just my ears I don't think I
could handle
um you know it's a skill they're fun and
they handled correctly
they're amazing and you can defend
yourself from a [__] lunatic which
makes a lot of sense when you live in
the middle of nowhere like I've said
there's like you're on your own out
there
so I understand that but my thing is
when they sit there and they go we'll
make it harder to get these assault
rifles and blah blah blah the argument
with people who have guns always seem to
be like so then what only the bad people
get guns
right which I understand that to a
certain extent but when I look at this
[__] idiot who shot up the the uh
the school out in Tennessee I really
don't see if she can't go to a [__]
Walmart or some local gun store to buy
this [__] I don't see that [__] wing
nut being able to navigate the dark web
and somehow get Henry Hill to show up to
her [__] doorstep half coped up with
a bunch of handguns with them where the
silencers don't fit them
so that's my thing about that where if
you make it harder I still think decent
people could could
um pass all those [__] tests and
still have their guns but these [__]
mental midgets
you know won't be able to just Waltz in
and like you know somebody's standing
behind a [__] counter at a Walmart at
a gun store they're not a psychologist
that's not their [__] job
they're not you know that's not good
they're not going to be able to figure
out that any more than I could
so that is my question like would if
they made it just a little more
difficult but you could still but you as
as a sane [__] person
could still go out and buy whatever gun
you wanted
is that it does that work
and I'm completely ignorant of the whole
thing but I was just curious to that
because you know it's funny like you
know liberals was saying like uh you
know they want to ban books
but they don't want to [__] ban guns
and then people going like [__] we
want to ban pornography
and [__] like that you know and then
there was some of that gender identity
[__] now I mean this is a whole nother
[__] can of worms
but I also respect people if they go hey
man listen that's my [__] job
I will talk about sex and gender
identity and all of that with my own kid
I don't want you guys doing it which I
gotta be honest with you I understand
that argument because I remember like
health class where they taught you about
sex and all of that [__] you know when
they were just doing the mainstream
regular old
you know all they talked about was
heterosexual [__] and they were even
[__] that up
it was like
the lack of [__] information they
would they would is your body so this is
how it works they should have been in
them being like listen you can get a
disease you could knock somebody up and
ruin your life
all right
this is you know
this is this is what love is this is
what you should be looking for this is
how you break up with somebody like that
there's like so much more that they
could be talking about
um and to leave it up to them I don't
know
I don't know they're probably gonna [__]
it up anyway but I understand both sides
where people with gender identity should
have like well we would like to be
considered mainstream enough to be
talked about in a public [__] school
so kids who are going through that don't
feel alienated so I understand that I
can basically kind of understand
everything and I wish everybody would be
like hey I can't understand the thing
let's [__] try to find a middle
ground instead of just hurling insults
at each other on social media
how about that
did that work at all on any law of
course my [__] agent calls me now
can't call me I do a [__] podcast I
never talk to this guy
oh Jesus Christ
all right I gotta take this God damn it
no me hung up now I don't have to take
it
um
anyway so that that that's my main
question about the gun thing is if you
could still get
you know all those assault weapons and
all that [__] that you want to get and
everything
but they made it a little more difficult
just because that person seemed pretty
[__] simple
you know
like that person as far as like trying
to navigate a a more difficult world to
get that gun
kinda seems like she would be like me
trying to navigate GarageBand and would
flip out and get upset and then say [__]
computers and maybe walk away as opposed
to doing that and then it would be nice
if CNN and fox and the New York Post and
all these [__] newspapers wouldn't
use these horrible stories
to try and make more [__] money
these are the same [__] too who come
after stand-up comedians about jokes and
meanwhile they're profiting off of
school shootings oh am I on my [__]
soapbox
and maybe I shouldn't come at them like
that I should ask them all right anybody
out there in journalism do you think
that like uh
one of the things contributing to this
idea that crazy people now have to go in
and do that is the amount of media
attention that it gets
is it is it like is that too simple to
fix it probably is if it came from my
simple brain I don't know
anyway let's get back to my simple life
I'm going uh out on the road
um
actually today when you listen to this
I'm going out on the road again on the
road again chicka boom chicka boom boom
boom and um
I gotta run of dates I'm gonna knock
them out and then I'm gonna retire and
that's it no it's not the truth but
that's what I want to say someday
not even retire I just enjoyed
hanging out being with my family and
stuff they're freaking awesome making
breakfast every day driving them to
school I would take both my kids to
school and they would be you know
arguing about the radio and [__]
it's kind of fun
and the other night I got into it you
know got a little back and forth my wife
my daughter's going I don't like when
you guys squabble that's what she said
and I said well you know that's it
happens
you know I was like you and your brother
were squabbling about the radio
she goes no we weren't I was like yeah
you were
it happens I'm gonna work on it I know I
know Dad you know
she's always my daughter always gets on
me going like Dad you s why do you
always say the bad words and I'm like
you know I don't always say them
but I do say them a lot I try not to say
them
and she's like why do you say them and I
said well
I grew up saying them I've been saying
him a long time so it's hard for me to
stop
and I don't know I don't know if that
works but like
you know she told one of the kids at
school
that I say the f word all the time and
it's my favorite word
fortunately
I'm friends with that other kid's parent
so
you know she told me Ania that and she
was laughing thought it was funny I was
just like oh brother
yeah Jesus
um just failing right and left here so
anyway
um
plowing ahead here oh my God the [__]
uh
the New York Yankees you know I read the
post this morning and they were going on
and on
they got they got this new [__] uh
shortstop coming up you know and as a
red stock sock fan I'm just sitting
there like really
like here we go again I mean it's just
what it's an unbelievable
I hate to say it it's a red star it's
just a [__] unbelievable franchise
like here they go again
their [__] Scouts have been crushing
it
it's it's
over a century now
so they got this new kid coming up
Anthony Volpe
and they're like oh he's super smart
both his parents are like in the medical
field he was gonna go to Vanderbilt
he won a couple of championships at the
high school level but uh the the Yankee
Scouts knew that if he went to
Vanderbilt he was going to crush it
there and he'd be too high a draft pick
and the Yankees would never have a
chance to get him but they knew that he
loved the Yankees so right but he
verbally commits to Vanderbilt they go
down they sit down and have breakfast
with them we say we believe in you you
can follow in the steps of your favorite
player Derek Jeter here we go
and he decides to commit to the Yankees
so I I don't know anything about this
kid other than he had an amazing spring
training so here's my question
that I asked uh two of my friends today
I said thoughts on Anthony volpley I had
to be a dick because of Yankee fans I
said thoughts on Anthony Volpe I go next
great Yankee or another New Yorker named
Tony that didn't do [__] with his life
uh that's gonna piss off a lot of people
over the age of 46.
um so I feel like that name's going away
like Anthony's going all these names are
[__] going away
um you know it's funny I've been doing
this bit about Armenians and I needed
like a nice generic Armenian name
and I did the bit in front of a table
full of Armenians and they all laughed
which is that's how I work those jokes
you know so I know I'm saying I'm right
I don't go by the laugh I look for the
the person that's in the group
and I go all right and if they're just
staring at me I'm like all right I'm I'm
not saying I'm not saying this the right
way because they're supposed to be
laughing along with me not looking at me
like I just said something [__] up so
fortunately
I said the Armenian joke right because
you don't want to [__] with those people
[Laughter]
so I said the joke right and afterwards
they came up to me
and I re I said was that right they go
100 100 I go am I wrong they go nope
you're not wrong and I was like all
right what is a generic
I need like the Anthony Tony [__]
Billy Bobby
uh Armenian name so they helped me out
so I want to say thanks to them
because uh I need I needed that name
for a tag that only like five people are
gonna get
but uh it's still worth it I just needed
the right name so um
I've been doing that I've been playing
my drums
you know I've been flying been working
out I've been drinking coffee I've been
laying off the cigars I basically
you know been hanging out with my kids I
just am enjoying this last week and I am
so thankful that I took this time off
and I am so thankful that the amount of
time I took off when I go back people
still want to see me so thank you to
everybody that's coming out in Ottawa
thank you to everybody that's going to
the Patrice O'Neill benefit and uh you
know I got some gigs in Maine New
Hampshire and
um old stomper grounds for me I want to
thank everybody for buying the friggin
tickets
so
um
you know I can keep having a fun job
I mean what what is there
to complain about
um
GarageBand
this is the [__] I complain about oh I
bring in my trash barrels in the car
door to my [__] wife's car keeps that
is [__] annoying one time it opened
up as my kid was walking around the
other side it almost like opened into
into my daughter's face and knocked her
down
you know what's funny I know I know if I
just went on YouTube
if I just went on YouTube
and just look that up there's a video
and someone will explain to me how to
fix that
and I've had the car for a couple of
years too that's all I need to do but
what happens is when I go onto the
internet
um
when I go on YouTube
I always end up seeing a video that I
want to watch and then I forget what I
was there
you know there's always going to be like
uh
Toronto Maple Leafs New York Rangers
1993 rough stuff I'm like well I gotta
watch that
gonna be some fights here I got I guess
you know who's on those teams
who's the tough guys there
who's that guy looked like Kirk Gibson
with the big [__] mustache one of the
great uh
maple leaves
not Willie pled it what was the guy's uh
it's gonna come to me
like man's man
hockey player
[__] anyway
see I watched that
there'll be some drumming video
that I Gotta See
um by the way I hung out with the great
Andrew femalis the other night
and he was playing uh
that band uh Night Moves highly
recommend them he played them for me a
while ago and I was blown away
by the talents of the people in that
band and I don't know just I kind of
drifted away and went back to my
you know baby boomer music that I
listened to slash 80s kid [__] and I
forgot to go back to it and now I
Revisited and bought their first album I
I got the one from 2012 and the one from
2019.
[Music]
um
incredible incredible like mesmerizing
music I'm enjoying the hell out of it's
great driving music
and uh
I was actually thinking there's a couple
of songs I would actually like to listen
to when I was flying but like
it's not how it works how about when I
go commercial right
when I get back out on the road again
um
anyway oh and I finished watching at
close range
uh Sean Penn Christopher Walken and uh
rest his soul Chris Penn Crispin Glover
and uh oh my God what's the what's the
woman who plays the love interest she's
[__] great in it I'm the worst
I'm the worst um but you got to see
um
this monologue Christopher Walken does
before he kills somebody like it doesn't
I don't understand what the metaphor for
is
he just has this dude in the woods and
he just goes I'm gonna do a really bad
Christopher Walken I'm just letting you
know I've done this for half of my
friends today on the phone he literally
just says to the kid he just goes uh
he's like
coyote [__]
is in heat
she satisfies
all the male coyotes and then she goes
to town
the dogs can smell it on her
you know his voice goes down
and he and he basically says
the coyote that's in heat the dogs can
smell that it's on heat lures one of the
dogs away and then the other coyotes
kill that dog
and I'm like all right
and then he just looks at the guy and he
goes you're going in front of the grand
jury
what are you going to say
dude it's like nothing
and he's and he goes dad and he goes
liar and he just shoots him
and I'm like
all right so is he
supposed to be that coyote [__] in heat
and like
the debt like satisfying the other guys
is he's the brains
and when they steal all those other
coyotes get to eat is it a metaphor
and now he's gone to town because he
can't trust this kid so he's drawn him
out so the other guys can kill him but
he kills them
and why would he be a coyote in heat I
mean you want to talk about gender
confusion maybe they should have that in
public schools I should go back and take
the class I don't know but you got to
see the monologue dude Christopher
Walken is so [__] amazing
he's so [__] Sinister in that goddamn
movie
um
and it holds up the movie holds up at
close range on Amazon you gotta check it
out all right if you guys have any
movies that you can recommend all right
I'm in a good mood again I I don't give
a [__] about
goddamn GarageBand let me read let me
read some uh copy here once I type in my
password I love how you got to do this
every [__] time
you know what I mean like I have CIA
documents here like my [__] laptop
ever goes anywhere
um
oh where the hell is it
what are you gonna say
all right policy genius everybody a good
life insurance plan can give you peace
of mind that if something happens to you
your family will have a safety net to
cover your mortgage payments College
costs or other expenses
um oh that was all the same sentence uh
so they can get back on their feet and
focus on what's important with policy
genius you can find life insurance
policies that start at just 25 per month
25 dollars per month for one million
dollars of coverage
but 25 bucks you can give your spouse
motive to whack you this is incredible
you might end up on the first 48. or
you know
if your dumbass goes up on a ladder and
comes down the hard way then they're not
going to be destitute there's a whole
bunch of ways to look at this some
options offer coverage
in as little as a week and avoid
unnecessary medical exams policy genius
has licensed agents who can help you
find the best fit for your needs they
work for you not the insurance companies
that means they don't have an incentive
to recommend one insurer over another so
you can trust their guidance there are
no added fees
and your personal details are private no
wonder they have thousands of five star
reviews on Google and trust and
trustpilot your loved ones deserve a
financial safety net you deserve a
smarter way to find and buy it head to
policy genius.com or click the link in
the description to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save that's
policygenius.com
p-o-l-i-c-y-g-e-n-i-u-s.com all right
so before I sign off here I really want
to hear from gun owners man you guys own
guns you went through the whole process
half of these stupid ass [__]
liberals talking I would say ninety
percent of them talking about don't own
guns don't understand the process don't
know what the [__] is going on so you
went through all of that you took the
gun safety thing you're shooting at
paper targets
right
yeah amping yourself up that you you're
gonna fight off a government if they get
too tyrannical and all of that [__] even
though they could have some nerd from
four states away fly a drone in and end
your [__] life while you're eating a
bowl of soup
um I wonder like what what would your
solution be where you could still get
your machine guns and all the [__] that
you want
um and [__] the rest of the world too
who are like oh my God this country's so
insane yeah it is it is insane
it is insane
this is [__] gangs in New York over
here this is how this whole [__]
thing went down it was not nice nobody
left everybody's still here this isn't
like [__] other countries where you
know you guys all crawled out of the
same [__] cave or whatever happened
all right we come from all the caves
over here
laughs
this is March Madness
there's brackets over here
um yeah and this whole [__] thing was
was done by Force and and all of this
[__] and it's just the train has left
the station so guns are here they're
here to [__] stay so let's let's have
the gun owners figure this [__] out help
me out here help a non-gun owner out
who's actually [__] open-minded
all right just to let you know in my
past I was a card carrying member of the
Prius family
um all right that is it that is all go
[__] yourselves have a nice weekend you
[__] ah my voice cracked you [__] I'll
see some of you bastards up there in
Ottawa I'll see some of the rest of you
in New York City I am very excited and
of course of course I get to see one of
the dreamiest men
that the big guy upstairs ever created
the one and only club soda Kenny all
right that's it enjoy the music from the
great Andrew femalis check out uh
night moves if you get a chance and
um you guys keep suggesting movies keep
sending me pictures old cars that you
think I should buy I love that [__] and
uh gun owners don't be shy I want to
hear from you let's try to figure this
out on this podcast that no one will
listen to when it comes to Solutions
because it's better to keep people
divided and yelling at each other so the
Ponzi scheme continues oh geez
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast from Monday
30th
March 30th everybody in like a lamb out
like a lion
remember I told you guys that I was
going to go to the [__] gym you
remember I said that
I remember that
you remember
oh my God Stacy you remember that
um
well oh Billy freckles [__] up this
week I went back to New York City New
York City is [__] an evil Twisted
place for me as far as uh I just have
too many friends too many comrades too
many booze bag Drinking Buddies I
[__] drank like Dean [__] Martin
all [__] week I went to the gym once
I played pickup hockey twice so that's
kind of like doing some cardio
uh I guess I walked to the subway and
went up and down the stairs other than
that other than that it was an absolute
it was a [__] show I put on display I
put on a display of [__] drinking
this past week I'm surprised
that like you know Maker's Mark is not
sending me like some sort of trophy with
their bottle on top of it all right
oh Jesus oh what did I what the [__] was
I doing you know what you know what New
York it's weird it's like you walk
around so it's good you know about
staying in shape but like the shit's
open all [__] night not everything by
the way because I remember back in the
day when I was a kid and they were like
it's the city that never sleeps it's
open 24 hours I used to think that meant
like Banks hardware stores like
everything was open it isn't all right
everything closes at a normal [__]
time like everything else except for the
places where you can really get in
trouble like bars
um and [__] late night places to eat
just every [__] dumb ass thing that
you could possibly do to wake up the
next morning looking like you're in your
first trimester
um that's what I did
coming home [__] hammered right
that's another thing too because there's
taxis all over the place you don't have
to even consider hey wait a minute I
have to drive you know I don't have to
drive
I don't have to do anything I have like
[__] 100 000 designated drivers out
there my friend my friend waiting to
take me home
and because I'm a white man even if I'm
just gonna walk home that's still
pulling over hey my friend my friend
right
it's a kind of privilege I have
being the blue-eyed devil right I can't
even walk off the [__] pounce
that's a form of terrorism right there
when you see a white guy that you know
needs to walk off the booze and you
[__] pull over and I'm not even
asking for a ride you still try to get
me to get in your cab because you hate
my country's foreign policy right there
you're like my friend my friend
get in my cup
you have heart attack when you're 50.
God is great right
how [__] hacky was that that was like
a a me doing a version of every stand-up
comics
um I guess Indian accent
well what do you expect I got to do one
of these every [__] week I got a
workshop some [__] that's gonna be some
hacky [__] on here what the [__] are you
doing I'm sending your desk with your
little pen and pencil set that your mom
and dad got you because they were so
proud of you
oh we're still proud of you here's a
penny pencil setting a stapler
you know what [__] your office supplies
what do you think about that [__] you
look at your desk
tell me right now you're not sitting at
your desk and you just don't have the
urge to [__] put you [__] arm down
on one side of it and just just clear it
right off
like Denzel Washington when he's in a
movie and the dialogue isn't up to his
acting level so he's got to start
slapping cups of water out of people's
hands just to make it seem compelling
huh
you know what's [__] up about Denzel
and Samuel Jackson can some though two
of the great [__] actors of of
whatever what do you say last 20 30
years right they keep sticking them in
those
like the blank movies right The
Negotiator
the [__] freelancer the architect
whatever the [__] it's always the
something
geez can you get him a [__] script
well you know what can you guys stop
stealing movies so the 50 million dollar
budget movie comes back you [__] instead
of everything being 100 million dollar
robots
you know with umbilical cords the aliens
whatever the [__] goes on in there right
it's either that or talking apes or what
do you have you got you got an
independent movie for [__] 800 Grand
which you know is gonna be a bunch of
awkward [__] nerds
you know with their [__] glasses
and they're [__] hoodies
anyways
anyways what are you gonna do let's
let's just plow I don't know what the
[__] I'm saying here all I'm telling you
is that you know last week after me
talking all this [__] that I should go
you know go step on the scale and see
what the damages I have to do that after
this podcast
I swear to God if I'm back up over 180
um I'm you might you might you know if
you listen
if you listen intently you might hear me
you might hear me weeping
oh man I'm [__] off the rails but it
starts today no it doesn't start today
it doesn't start today you know because
I was out of town
and uh you know my wife's been super
busy and uh you know there's nothing in
the fridge my truck is getting fixed I
don't have a vehicle
and you know what I got up you don't
have upstairs in the fridge I have week
old lunch meat and I have some [__]
guacamole
because my wife saves all take out she
just sticks it in there and she I mean
every [__] little thing it's it's
insane
she's like a hoarder of of of leftovers
like little [__] every packet of
sauce
anytime we order sushi she sticks all
those [__] packets and they're like
you know God Fitbit someday a [__]
mackerel falls through our ceiling we
gotta eat the whole thing we'll have
enough soy sauce
right those things old chopsticks
little tins of sour cream you know those
little things that are
[__] balsamic vinaigrettes like and
then once every every three months I
gotta be the bad guy
I got to be the guy that goes in there
Hey listen everybody you know
like I'm kicking some bum out that was
supposed to get an apartment come on
guys you gotta go all right get up off
the couch
you took guacamole you're out
gosh it looks like a container of [__]
that's what I have upstairs I have a
container of Brown guacamole I already
threw it out
you know what I mean
I'm [__] I got one can of dog food
I don't know what she did this weekend
you know buddy but you can't give him
[__] you give them [__] and then what
they get mad at you
they get mad at you they get mad at you
when they didn't do the broad job of
keeping the [__] refrigerator stocked
that is a woman's job go [__] yourself I
don't care if you have hair under your
armpits and not that's a [__] woman's
job the same way my job is I gotta take
the [__] trash out to the curb
there's certain things
that were and always will be a man or a
woman job around the [__] house and I
just feel you know keeping the [__]
refrigerator stocked
you know
for your hero
for your inspiration
for the man in your life I don't think
that that's asking too [__] much is
it
I don't think it is
oh Jesus Christ
whatever I had a [__] bowl of
Cinnamon life this morning one of my
[__] eight years old those are my
options you know I would have had the
oatmeal but there's no banana I gotta
have a banana with the [__] oatmeal
you know you know this about me
ah Jesus Christ why even why even get
involved in the [__] argument Bill
how long have you been with you know
better
don't take the bait just [__] sit
there and be like oh yeah always say
nothing in the fridge oh that's great
thank you sweetheart
oh you have a good day bye bye
hey Cleo you want us you want to split a
[__] can of dog food
you must remember this
Just a Kiss
um I came home anyways I wanted first of
all before I uh
do any more babbling here
you know in the podcast I want to thank
um everybody over at Madison Square
Garden this week for uh asking me to
come over and do the garden of Dreams
The Garden of Dreams
um benefit this week I could not have
had a better time I went to a Rangers
game I went to a Celtics game
you know we played pickup hockey we've
listened to the Thursday podcast we
played pickup hockey at Madison Square
Garden
you know
unbelievable
the hardest thing I had when I was there
at Madison Square Garden skating on the
ice the only thing harder than trying to
keep my heart rate my heart literally
from jumping out of my chest the only
thing harder was trying to find a
championship Banner hanging from the
rafters
[Music]
they got all kinds of banners up there
they got banners up there for like
division championships I mean it's a sad
thing it's such a wonderful Arena ah
come on as a Boston fan you know I had
to break a little bit of balls but it
was uh it was tremendous and um we
couldn't had a better time and I have
the the puffy booze face
to uh to prove it I had a uh
I had a great [__] time
um and now I'm back
and I believe me when I told you this
morning that I rolled out of bed let me
tell you I rolled out of bed you know
I'll tell you last week I had a rough
one
um
anyways
so like a uh
I come home last night
and uh I got home late
back out here in LA and uh me and the
wife watched that Scientology movie
on um
on HBO
and you definitely should check it out
all right but if you if you don't sit
down before you even watch the first
second of it
and say to yourself that they could
literally do the exact same documentary
on every [__] religion on this planet
um then you probably shouldn't watch it
because you're gonna be one of those
people that watches the Scientology
video and be like dude these people look
[__]
um it's all [__]
it's everything that they're doing
was I I can't speak for a religion my
religion did
times a zillion as far as I know
Scientology for as abusive as they're
they're claiming that they've been they
never killed anybody
you know
they didn't go around [__] children
like my [__] organization
I don't have one rock to rock I don't
have one rock to throw
but um I will tell you man they um
it was it was just more of the same I
watched it more like not just looking at
it like this is Scientology this is what
the [__] it is I looked at it more like
uh
just like human beings and this is what
happens when somebody
is allowed to slide into the Jesus
position
Muhammad whatever you want to call it
when they slide in there
who's who's the Jewish guy
who's that who's there Jesus was there
some guy named is it I can't that's too
hack you have to say some guy named
Murray
uh Abraham is that that guy I don't
[__] know I have no idea all sound
the same to me
there was nothing nothing was going on
and then this guy showed up he did a
bunch of great [__] and now he's the guy
give us your money
is it okay if uh she blows me
um anyways plowing ahead here um you
should definitely uh highly recommend uh
let you check that out and um
I don't know I felt bad for Tom Cruise
they made him look like a sucker
you know what I mean especially you know
anytime you know you slow down the video
and you put weirdo music in there you're
gonna make somebody look bad
and um
yeah I don't know what the [__] I mean
when I sit there and I think of the [__]
that I bought into
going into a goddamn booth and telling
some [__] weirdo all the bad things I
did that week what is that all about
huh bless me five five CNG has been shot
engaged since my last [__] confession
I jerked off I beat up my brother I
[__] stole it's just like
and this guy's just sitting in there
what the [__] are you doing in there you
weirdo
listening to all this [__] I gotta go
there and confess to you you [__] why
can't I just go right go direct route
why do I gotta connect in [__] Dallas
talking to you why can't I just [__]
go straight there no direct flight to
God there buddy what are you doing in
there hey
what's going on the other side of the
wall there
what are you doing your weirdo
ah you're filming this [__] in case I
want to run for office someday or
[__] call you out for banging a kid
you got all this weird footage on me
I don't know all of it is [__] weird
I think everyone I think everybody
should just walk away from all of that's
what I that would be my suggestion you
don't have to but if it works for you
fine
um unless you become a [__]
oh Jesus Bill why do you try to make
points why they never go anywhere did
they go anywhere I don't think they do
um
so anyways what did I do this week Jesus
am I running out of [__] to say already
it's already 15 minutes in I think I
gotta [__] read some ads
just to keep it going so I uh
Mike I told you guys my truck uh um I
don't know I cooked the valves on it man
I [__] so pissed at myself so they're
uh they're rebuilding the whole thing
the whole engine brand new I can use
unleaded gas it won't [__] the thing up
and uh it should be done sometime this
week I actually uh adding air
conditioning and I'm getting the power
steering
and um that's just gonna be my [__]
daily driver and I kept the three on the
tree because it was just too [__]
cool this guy was building is going like
dude we can [__] it we can get this
thing cruising at about 100 miles an
hour it's just like
I don't want to do that it's too [__]
cool shifting on the column you know I
think is too [__] cool to uh
to get rid of that so
um basically
I'm gonna have a badass [__] truck
here in a couple of days
which would be nice because then maybe I
could [__] you know throw Cleo and
then I could go down the street and I
could maybe put something in the
refrigerator or maybe I could eat
something
oh let me tell my wife you know she
doesn't I got a wife you know she
doesn't she doesn't stock the
refrigerator
why just the other day
um anyways uh let's uh let's let's read
a little bit of uh advertising
for the week I swear to God I know I
must have saw something they had him and
you know what I just had a [__]
tremendous week
I don't know what to tell you I enjoyed
myself all week I did the um
I did the benefit for uh
versus brother-in-law and I actually uh
had a great time up there at Levity Live
which is a [__] unbelievable comedy
club by the way I had always heard there
was one of the best in the country and
it definitely lived up to it and um I'm
trying to uh
figure out a way where I can get back
there at some point Tarrytown played the
Terrytown Music Hall which was the last
second gig
and um
it was fun man I'm back
you know we got the we got the cartoons
all recorded we got all the records are
done
and uh now the drawing the [__] and we
just I don't know my schedule's totally
opened up now and I can get back to
being a stand-up comic and I can't
[__] wait I can't wait for the
southern tour and oh Billy's [__]
cigar face still has not had a cigar all
right
I'm coming up on like five weeks
remember when I told you guys I was
gonna be that guy who smoked a cigar
once a week that's what I was trying to
do I was trying to cut down my cigar
smoke into a mere 52 cigars A year which
is still way too much so after [__]
January and February I was already up to
12 cigars eight weeks 12 cigars I'm off
the [__] rails already so I didn't
smoke anything in March
um we're already up to the 12th week so
now I feel like I'm even but um
you know I told virgin those guys that I
wasn't going to
um
I wasn't going to uh smoke
until the uh the bus tour and then I was
gonna smoke but I gotta be honest with
you I might not even smoke on that one
I might just wait till my birthday
because I figured my birthday's in June
and then what if I'm still on 12 cigars
now I'm down to like two a month which
seems way more [__] acceptable
than uh
I don't know I had my fun with it I if
it didn't give you mouth throat and
[__] God knows what else other kind
of tongue cancer
I would uh I would probably smoke for a
week that's how much I enjoy him but I
just I don't know
I don't know I've seen Leonard Nimoy die
and saying he regretted smoking and he
was like 83 80 45 years old and you're
still thinking [__]
if I didn't do that I would keep you
know most people young people you look
at you look 83 dude I'd be [__] happy
with 80. yeah until you're [__] 80.
and you're staring death in the face and
you're like [__] you know
I wish I just drank Waters and [__]
was a vegetarian or whatever the [__]
you're thinking so the fact that he was
still thinking he would think if you
smoked and you still made it to 83 80 45
whatever the [__] it was eight three
eight forty five
um you'd be like yeah whatever I had a
good run
that's what you're thinking to you that
person laying in the bed right wearing
that Smock with your ass hanging out of
it and you're like wow this is it
this is it I'm not gonna get to watch
any more hoop anymore hockey I'm not
gonna get to walk down the street listen
to the birds chirping this is [__] it
it's over
and it's over sooner than it should have
been because I [__] said I can't get
it out of my head so I don't know I
think I'm done
no who's kidding who
I'm not done but I mean I am uh
I I don't know I don't want to pick it
back up again because I I you know you
know what the [__] happens right you're
trying to eat right just like I was I go
to New York and I have one slice of
pizza and all of a sudden I'm eating
like some [__]
fat guy on Prom Night who didn't have a
date because it was pathetic I'm ashamed
of myself
you guys want every fat shame myself go
walk into the bathroom mirror huh you
want to hear this I'm gonna do it right
now I'm gonna show you what fat shaming
is all about right here this is what it
is right
all right let's see if Bill let's see
the tears
look at that
you're a piece of [__]
[__] oatmeal dude I gotta stop you know
I just realized
I have to stop
because my neighbors will think I'm
actually yelling at my wife
so that's it fortunately
I got my pull-up bar my dip station out
in the garage
I'll do that oh my body literally just
reacted when I said that you know what I
go I want my pizza see that I got the
grease in me right now I got the crack
I'm on the crack right now that's what I
did in a food way
you know I was craving salads I was
craving [__]
healthy food one slice of pizza and a
couple of [__] beer you know what we
went off the rails was right after we
skated right
um
you know [__] exhausted totally wiped
out and uh
we were gonna we were going to the
outside we were going to the Rangers
Kings game that night so we went to a
bar
and uh ordered an appetizer and I
ordered this [__] beer uh there's
nothing better after he played hockey
and you really feel like you earned the
fact that you could actually sit down
and have a beer because you burned so
many calories
and um
easily the best beer I've had in like
six months it was [__] delicious and
I remember sitting there and I was
eating [__] already that wasn't healthy
and this switch just went
like in my body I literally felt it like
oh are we doing this
huh is it like you know it was like
substitute teacher like is is the douche
gone now we can go back to boozing and
eating greasy [__] food
I bought ice cream this week I haven't
had [__] ice cream unless I even
[__] had ice cream
stupid ass [__] New York walking home
hammered stumble into a deli oh let me
get bacon egg and cheese on a roll how
you doing I ain't got any [__] next
thing you know I got that I bought
Fritos and then I bought a pint of
[__] cookies and cream ice cream
right what am I on my period
[__] go back to the goddamn thing
wolf it down I went easy on the ice
cream but I just was [__] over
sitting there eating like I'm at [__]
seventh grade and cafeteria
all right let's um
let's get on with the uh oh by the way
somebody gave me something when uh when
I was
playing hockey one day
I've never heard of this it's called
Junk bomb
bomb like like a roll-on and it's
literally deodorant for your balls is
that not the funniest [__] thing ever
and the guy's giving it to me and he's
going well you know he's like if you
know if you played hockey you don't have
time to take a shower you just put this
on your balls
[__] are you serious I swear to God this
is a real thing
so I'm laughing and I'm like well [__]
if you got Sherry's Berries
you know
if we got [__] one white Charlie's
how do you not have junk but I met I
gotta have junk bomb on on the podcast
so if any of those guys are listening it
would fit right in
hey guys don't have time to take a
shower
Jesus dude if you don't if your [__]
balls are smelling to the point that you
smell them I mean Jesus you don't have
[__] time to take a shower yeah I
gotta make time
hey honey I'm gonna be a little late
trust me you're gonna thank me later
all right here we go
anyways where are we 29 minutes and I'll
tell you a couple more [__] stories
then we'll get into the questions for
the week wouldn't that be nice
wouldn't that be a nice thing
what's going on in the world
what about that [__] jerk off that
flies the [__] plane into the Alps I
mean
I mean Jake are you kid are you
you're depressed to that [__] level
it's one of the worst goddamn things I
I've
why the [__] would I bring that up you
know what I mean [__] that one
if there was a couple of there was a
couple oh we'll tell you a couple
Aviation things this week you know
um up in Canada
they came into [__] low I guess and
they they entered they had some sort of
Tower or some [__]
Jesus Christ
that's I fly all the [__] time man
that [__] is absolutely terrifying
um
I just can't imagine what kind of level
of [__] depression you have
I get it you know
bad enough you'd go out and you'd harm
yourself you'd never want to see that
but you go and you take out all those
other goddamn people man it's just the
worst
[__] story ever in this you know what
and there's absolutely no comedy in it
and now here we sit
I'll tell you what there was no comedy
in oh here's a Segway
somebody sent me this picture this is
the saddest [__] pictures I ever seen
it was of a seal that was born
like a redhead
and all the entire seal Community just
rejected this seal and they take this
[__] picture of this seal
and it's all by itself and looking way
off in the distance or all the other
seals that it just wants to hang out and
play with you know and learn how to
[__] fish and not get eaten by a
shark or whatever
and they just totally leave it alone
it's unbelievable
this is just like we're [__] animals
same thing same [__] treatment I got
on the goddamn playground it's happening
to a [__] seal I saw that seal you
know what kills me it's the people that
like take pictures of it don't interfere
in nature
it's like would it kill you to take that
thing home with you
just get one of those above ground pools
you know let the [__] thing hang out
a couple times a year it comes in for
the Super Bowl you know come up on the
couch there redheaded seal I feel your
pain
I have empathy who do you got
don't [__] say Seattle you gotta be
back outside
um it's one of the saddest [__]
pictures I've ever seen I can't get it
out of my it just it [__] killed me
[__] kill me it's unreal
it's unreal the human things that I can
laugh at but you show me a [__] sad
animal and it crushes me it's why I
stopped watching the Discovery Channel
like a decade ago I don't watch any
[__] nature shows because I know how
it's gonna start it's gonna start with
me being all wide-eyed and excited and
enjoying the program and then in this
the inevitable and then man came and
[__] everything up
I'll tell you right now if you work for
a [__] Corporation I mean
can you can you slowly work your way out
and not working for one
is it even possible I was watching did
you guys see that clip I retweeted it
somebody sent it to me of uh you know
they're doing that fracking out in uh
Nebraska
horizontal drilling whatever the [__] it
is and
however they go about it people are
claiming
that it that it pollutes the [__]
drinking water
so this farmer comes in he talks about
all the great drinking water that they
have in Nebraska and then he pours in
the goop
he's sitting there at this town meeting
and he's allowed to talk so he asks
these [__] that work for the fracking
companies said hey would you would you
drink this water I just want you to
answer me that would you drink this
water and then the [__]
chairman of the board goes you're not
allowed to ask them questions
all you're allowed to do is come up and
make comments
it's like when what the [__] are we
doing here
this is supposed to let me just say what
I have to say and then I run along and
then you [__] let these guys destroy
the drinking water in this state because
you don't make any [__] money as a
politician
I don't know I watched that thing and
I gotta commend that that that
Nebraska guy for [__] not flipping
out
oh you know I'm just allowed to make
comments well here's my comment at least
go and dump it over their [__] heads
what kind of [__] people are involved
in a goddamn business like that that
ends up polluting the [__] drinking
water
and you're so thinking about all you
give a [__] is your next quarter profits
like where is that all gonna go
like where where does what's the end
game in that you just keep having a more
profitable thing then there's no more
clean drinking water and then what
you've made enough money to have the
machine to [__] have make sure you
have clean drinking water and everybody
else [__] dies and you somehow
justify it is you lie in your giant
[__] bed
ah
it's so [__] depressing I mean that's
why I I sit around I watch sports I
watch people build cars those are like
the two [__] areas that I can kind of
stay in
where I can kind of uh I don't know
nobody says anything racist nobody
pollutes drinking water and it's not a
redheaded seal who just wants to be part
of the [__] group
just sitting there looking all sad the
thing was a [__] baby
she had a baby man and they just said
they [__] you know I'd [__] seals I'm
going you know what [__] all those
[__] seals I'm glad they get eaten by
those goddamn sharks I used to give a
[__] about seals now that I know that
they're [__] racist
bunch of [__] you know what it is too I
bet there was some seals down there that
didn't give a [__] they just went along
with the group and sat there silently
right as the one bully seal ah Jesus
bill is this about the seals of your
[__] childhood
all right all right let's get to the uh
let's get to the goddamn questions for
the week
it always kills me when they can do that
and just don't interfere with nature and
you're just gonna sit there and look at
that sad [__]
all right if you by the way if you want
to uh follow us on Twitter here
um the podcast Twitter handle is at the
mm podcast
and the
uh beyonding here and the podcast email
is Bill the
mmpodcast.com once again that number is
Bill at the mmpodcast.com
all right that's if you want to send an
email you know what I just realized too
is my internet sucks in this house I
don't have a car right now I got my
crazy Pitbull so I can't even drive down
to the local [__] coffee shop to use
their internet to upload this [__]
thing so hopefully
uh what the [__] you gonna do what if
it's [__] late it's late what am I
gonna do all right oh by the way
um I got a big guess this week oh let me
tell you got a big guest for the
Thursday uh just checking in with your
[__] podcast whatever the hell I'm
calling it but it's actually gonna go
down on Friday but you'll be happy
you will be happy when you hear the
guest I got a big guest he is the star
of my favorite new show
do you know what the show is
huh
post-apocalyptic show
former SNL cast member
Action Hero
you know who he is he's gonna be on this
Friday all right
here we go that's called the teaser
um
Warehouse listeners Bill I'm 19 and I
work in a warehouse part-time oh my God
the most fun job you'll ever [__]
have I was 19 when I worked in a
warehouse and I worked there part times
[__] greatest he said I've introduced
your podcast to the guys there and we
listen to it regularly you've come full
circle
oh is that oh that was just the uh thing
well that's cool what are you guys been
doing huh
[__] off there in the warehouse and
all of a sudden somebody with a tie
comes on you're like who's that you
start acting like you're [__] moving
boxes around
I really missed that [__] job
do you know the way I traveled you know
back in the day when I worked in a
warehouse my commute to work was a
little over a mile
like we lived in like the last
neighborhood before there was this
Industrial Park
um like if I rode a bike's bicycle to
work it'd probably take me 15 minutes
and there was weeks where I would put
like
you know I'd go to work
and then I would drive home
and then I would work out listen to
Appetite for Destruction I'd lift
weights throughout that whole [__]
album and then I'd jump on a bike
uh buy my bicycle and I do like a
[__] 10 mile
bike ride
and then by then you know it was like
seven o'clock or so
in the Bruins of Celtics or wherever
they had a game and I was in for the
night and I would do that
right up until Friday
so Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday I
probably put like 12 miles on my truck I
had this 83 Ford Ranger that I bought
and we had 19 317 miles and I remember I
owned that [__] thing for forever
I drove that truck for [__] 10 years
um even after it started rusting out
from all the New England Winters but I
remember like I I put on so few few
miles until I became a comedian and then
I went through the roof and then I
remember
um the engine [__] the bed
and um
there was a critical moment in my life I
had a day job and everyone was saying I
should go out and go buy a new car
and um
I just kept thinking if I buy a new car
then I got payments then I need to have
a job so I said [__] it and I just
hadn't put a new engine in it
I told you this story remember that girl
that woman at work was like that was
stupid
that was stupid really I don't have a
[__] car payment
hey guess what I'm quitting my day job
to move to New York City see ya
you know have fun with your Ultima
um anyway sorry
all right fat shaming counter argument
uh all right dear Billy Ginger balls
this guy's gonna counter fat shaming by
[__] trashing me okay he sounds like
an open guy all right I love your
podcast and I listen each week I'm a
chubby guy who's working hard to lose
some of my ex XXX weight
I'm down from 240 to 215. there you go
dude that's a big change 240 to 215 that
is [__] come on Bill do the math
that's 25 pounds
it's 125 miles of capillaries out the
[__] window however I would argue
that despite the name you've given to
your discussions you aren't fat shaming
anyone and that's a good thing you are
more of a coach than a true fat shamer
dude I know what I'm doing
I'm not going to depress you I'm gonna
get you in that mindset
you know you're better than that
when you were a kid you laid in that
crib you did not dream of having man
tits
I know how to do it I know how to give
you [__] while I [__] uplift you
um a fat shamer is a person who looks at
an old boy person says you're worthless
you are of a you are a failed person and
you can't do anything to fix yourself
who the [__] says that
you sound like that dude in that
Drummond movie
you [__] piece of [__] that's why I
couldn't I couldn't get into whiplash
after like the first 20 minutes of that
guy getting screamed at the fact that he
didn't have the self-esteem to get up
and walk out it's just it's like all
right now I don't give a [__] it was
like Gone Girl
you know
if you haven't seen it yet block your
ears for the next [__] 15 seconds
okay I'm gonna talk about it in three
two one the fact that after he found out
what the [__] she did and then she comes
back and then Tyler Perry's like you
[__] are crazy and walks out
and like he stays with her at that point
it's like hey you know I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] if she [__]
kills the Ben Affleck character right
now because that Ben Affleck character
does not seem to give a [__]
that's how I felt with like Whiplash
it's like all right you know if
you don't have to get yelled at to play
drums well but if you feel that you do
and you want to sit there then then
you're a [__] jackass
see that's what I do I'm empowering you
huh to get off the couch and you know
how you get off the couch you know just
don't get off the couch you got to lift
your [__] legs do a little rolly back
into the couch yeah we go right
that should be your next goal when you
get up off the couch you just get up off
the couch that's a milestone that's a
marker right there well you don't have
to do the onesie twosy and then [__]
get all the way up
literally
sounded like you're doing a squat like
that last one of the set
yeah when you get up off the couch
waking the baby scaring the family dog
you can't be like that he said anyways
to me you're a coach who says you're
healthy you can fix this but it won't be
easy but it's worth it absolutely
absofucking lutely I really think that
so much of uh staying in shape
is um
is being conscious
of craving something that you know is
going to make you feel like [__]
afterwards and hate yourself in the
morning when you're belly's sticking out
even more like last night I'm coming
home from the airport and I am on the
crack
all right pizza ice cream potato chips
beer whiskey the whole [__] week and
I'm coming home what do you think I'm
craving you think I'm craving a [__]
salad no what is the thing I need the
most of [__] giant salad that will go
into me it'll be nutrition with a bunch
of [__] cancerous poison on every
leaf that I try to rinse off but I'm
doing the best I can well whatever but
what we'll do it'll level me off
chemically and I don't even have a
[__] Science Background but I know
it's gonna it's like
you know it's like you're in a ship
that's rocking you're getting into to to
stable water calm seas and you can make
an intelligent Choice all right so last
night what I should have done is I knew
it I was saying you should order I
literally have heartburn I should go you
should order a [__] salad that's what
you should do
and I was conscious enough to think that
and I still went inside and I went and I
made myself waffles with [__] butter
and syrup and all that and you know this
morning I wake up and you know because I
ate that last night I'm looking at
oatmeal and then I'm looking at cinnamon
life and what do I do more heroin more
heroin and I go with that
so um
I'm
but at least I'm aware of it so right
now I have to like critically right now
like what I decide to eat right now for
lunch can literally inform the next
three months of decisions if I'm not
careful and I can put on 10 to 15 pounds
just because last night I didn't order a
[__] salad and then where are you
then you [__] back at the gym because
you not because you want to be because
you have to be and you got that big
[__] lump of [__] you gotta you gotta
take off from your middle
like you eat your way in you eat your
way out of the gym so I have to today
make a [__] smart choice
um
and I gotta get I gotta get back on the
stick so uh congratulations to you going
from 240 down to 215 whatever you're
doing
um
hope it works and I hope you're reading
up on nutrition I hope you're not doing
one of those fad diets
you know any of those Beach diets or any
of those you know I'm cutting out carbs
I'm never having bread again you know
that type of [__] because you know
eventually one day you're just gonna sit
down with an entire you can have one
loaf of bread in one hand and a stick of
butter in the other with some ice cream
waiting in the fridge if you [__] do
that to yourself
um
I don't know I've actually I've actually
thought about just writing down
like because everybody oh this is my
cheat day like your cheat day can
literally like that'd be like a drug
addict like all right I'm not gonna do
drugs but on Sunday I'm gonna do heroin
and then the next day it's right back to
clean living
um
like your cheat day can literally throw
you off chemically to the point the next
day you're eating [__] waffles like
an [__]
um but maybe if you write it down
you know that this is what you're going
to have and then you write a short
paragraph hey you know hey [__] face
listen
why don't you eat this for breakfast
rather than [__] up for the next
three weeks and putting on 20 pounds
you know once you're listening too when
you order something healthy we eat two
three bites into it
like this calm comes over you like ah
like nutrition you know what I mean I
read this great thing one time why you
can eat so much Chinese food or why you
can eat a whole [__] bag of Doritos
even though you've eaten enough to be
full but your body is still craving
nutrition and there's not an ounce of
nutrition in that [__] so despite the
fact that you took a whole [__] bag
of it and threw it down your goddamn pie
hole your body's immediately it's still
crate craving nutrients vitamins or
whatever the [__] it is whatever the
proper terminology is for it
um
which is also why if you eat actually
you know fruits and vegetables you get
you get full
um
oh it's you know what I gotta I have to
make sure I eat well I really do this
isn't even about you guys [__] about
me I'm being selfish right now let's get
back to more uh
let's get back to more [__] emails
here for the week uh naming food places
all right hey Bill
you recently asked about places to eat
as your tour of the great lower half of
this country is about to begin I've been
a long time listen
and I get you no name policy when it
comes to telling stories that may be
incriminating or name-dropping but you
said you didn't want to say the names of
the restaurants out of fear that it
would ruin the place by creating some
type of mom seed and the food will go
downhill and it'll get franchised or
something Bill come on now
you're basically repaying them for their
hard work possibly generations of hard
work by walking out by walking out and
disavowing all knowledge of the place
the way the U.S government handled
Vietnam Jesus or more specifically John
Rambo and Rambo 2. on behalf of all
these establishments I'd like to thank
you for being
uh for helping protect them from
increased revenue and supporting a
health healthy sense of pride in a
life's work also I'd like to thank you
on behalf of people like myself who
occasionally travel who would much
rather just walk around and play
guessing games about where to eat it's
much more fun playing will this suck
roulette we'd much rather trust Yelp
reviews that are probably real people
and not paid reviewers or family members
hyping some [__] establishment Circa
2011.
a real man of the people this Bill Burr
get him a key to all the cities
sci-fi Billy Skywalker you know what
dude you had me until you [__]
glorified all the [__] on Yelp
Yelp I swear to God is like if you want
to see what happens to somebody when
they get their own TV show and how most
people's egos go through the [__]
roof all you have to do is just looking
at look at the Common Man on Yelp
no everything was good but I didn't like
the sugar packets
these [__] animals have you seen the
average jerk off that walks down the
[__] Street breathing through their
mouth wearing socks and [__]
flip-flops
those [__] [__] who obviously
have no power in their life they go on
Yelp and their [__] ego goes off the
[__] rails here's something what do
you think happened back in the day when
people went to town before Yelp and I
don't mean the 1950s I'm talking about
the [__] 1980s the 1990s you know
what you struck up a conversation with
the locals you said hey I'm in town I'm
having a really good time I'd like to
get some food you know of a good place
there's nothing a local wants to do more
than to point you to the place that is
this [__] in that town and you go in
there and you sit down and you have a
[__] unbelievable meal and then you
go back and you tell your friends hey if
you ever go there you got to go to this
spot the fact that it has to blow up
like some [__] boy band and now
nobody can get a goddamn seat in there
give me a [__] break I stand by what
I'm doing and you know why I get
Applause when I say that
I went to a country recently I said this
place is so [__] beautiful that when
I go back to my country I'm not going to
talk about it
so you know I'll keep you secret you
know what they all did they I gotta
almost I got borderline standing ovation
all right everything doesn't need to
blow up
all right I don't need to turn every
[__] restaurant into [__] Kim
Kardashian's greased up ass on the yo it
broke the internet
dumbest [__] thing ever broke the
internet and then every [__] douche
that's out there taking selfies has to
somehow squeeze broke the internet into
their [__] conversation I [__]
hate that I hate internet uh terminology
I hate the joke structure you know the
said no one ever or the uh you know now
it's like you have like a picture and
you're like
that look on your face when your boss
says you don't have to come in Friday
that [__]
you know insert picture here so you
don't even have to be like a joke writer
so dude with all due respect
with your waving of the [__] American
flag all right here's the deal if you
get in the [__] job done
all right if you get in the [__] job
done and everybody in the local Town
knows you this [__] you're gonna stay in
business you don't need me to [__]
hype your thing and then ruin it like
the Food Network does and speaking of
which too that [__] guy there with
his bleach blonde hair and his sunburned
face Guy Fieri driving all around
I'm telling you that [__] guy I I've
gone to some of the places he's they hit
or miss
they hit or miss that guy's been on the
air for like 10 years he's out of places
to go to not to mention he never goes to
drive-ins
he occasionally goes into diners he
never goes into a dive they're basically
diners but he needed the magic of three
um anyways so no I'm not doing that okay
if you know how to make a [__]
brisket the goddamn word is going to be
out
all right the word's gonna get out you
don't need me to do it and uh ruin
ruin the [__] place Jesus Christ
Yelp what kind of a [__] [__] goes
on to Yelp
it just takes all these [__] people
you have no idea what their [__] ax
is to grind I think that there's like a
certain level of [__] that you have to
be to even post a review on Yelp
not to mention there's so many [__] on
Yelp that this restaurants that I've sat
in
and I said hey I really enjoyed that
that was delicious and they go thank you
can you please go on Yelp and write a
good review
because there's just so many people yeah
you know I'm really dirty eggs when
you're shopping
they have a little bit of power now and
I'm gonna [__] Furrow my brow
have you noticed that [__]
all you need to know about Yelp is just
look at actual critics that get paid
to be critics
when was the last time you saw him
review any [__] movie any [__]
movie at all and wired a wire they said
that they enjoyed it they never do they
always have to be [__] they always have
to pick out something that they didn't
[__] like
all right and then what else then you'll
see the worst [__] movie ever and
they have quotes going outrageous
hilarious a laugh Riot and all that is
is critics that want to get paid so they
got to get their name out there so then
they'll [__] lie to you and say that
some piece of [__] is actually good so
[__] you [__] Yelp and [__] Rambo too
all right I'm not I'm not out in those
places
all right there we go I don't know about
[__] Rambo too
okay check out dark city oh hey Billy
sci-fi uh Billy Skywalker all right I
thought that was somebody signing that
um
what the [__] is with all these God damn
Jesus seats here we go it's starting
it's starting
um
oh [__] did you see my email did you
check out the hotel options sci-fi Billy
Skywalker
check out dark city oh I asked last week
uh you know I really enjoyed
um
uh Moon
with Sam Rockwell and I didn't realize
the director was David Bowie's son which
of course I don't have his [__] name
here right now I'm the worst
um so I said what are some other Sci-Fi
movies I'd love to check them out and
somebody says uh Billy Skywalker check
out dark city it's not action-packed but
like Moon you gotta see it it shot
beautifully intense as [__] it's on HBO
right now don't delay also if you
haven't seen Blade Runner recently give
it a re-watch
um your fellow pilot Harrison Ford
delivers a really underrated performance
make sure you watch the director's cut
it's the only way it'll make sense
oh wow I got a [__] uh
I gotta check that out
um
oh my God what is this this seems like a
disaster waiting to happen
listen to this one kitten for Cleo
Bill have you ever thought of getting a
kitten to help calm Cleo down
I can't imagine Cleo having a problem
with it oh I can't
oh I can't
I imagine it'd be possible for Cleo to
eventually become protective of the
kitten which would could turn into
making things
worse
so why would I do that
I'll let you do the research but if you
had to imagine how it played out what do
you think would happen
um I think my dog would eat the cat
I think she would view it as a threat
because she's possessive and I think I
would come home and the dog would be
wagging its tail with fur around its
mouth and blood on its chin
and I would find maybe well kitten it'd
probably be swallowed whole but they
might be a [__] paw in my kitchen or
something else horrific that I'd have to
try and block out
um
I remember when they taught that gorilla
how to do sign language they get they
got that thing a pet cat
I don't know
a kitten
I'm not I'm not a big fan of cats I
totally respect him
how they live their lives and their
anti-authority and like you know the
same way you couldn't put me in a leash
you can't put them on a leash although I
know a few people have done it but
whatever I'm just saying generally
speaking
um
the only thing I like about cats
I like watching them sleep in the Sun
reminds me to take an old man nap every
day and then I also like how easy it is
to discipline them
you know all you do is just give a nice
little smack on that little [__] nose
and then they get it you know no I'm
kidding all you have to do is just have
the the spray water
bottle right
and they're still going to go up in the
couch but it's just fun to [__] shoot
something that doesn't die and you get
to feel that cool feeling of shooting
something
you know I don't know is that evil
well go [__] yourself what do you want
from me
um all right
let me let me read the last little bit
of advertising I'll tell you a cute
story and then that's going to be a
[__] week what do you think about